hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play refuge or
refugee if you're from Europe so this is
a game that I found or someone
recommended to me from in ddb you can
find it in the link below I don't know
much about it it's in beta at the moment
so don't expect too much from it but it
is indie horror ish made on the Unity
engine in case you were curious haha
what I'm I'm all alone I've got my mouse
there though where am I
why is it so dark my eyes aren't
adjusting I must be dreaming
my office block is dark and feels
different somehow sorry the mouse is in
there I that's just something with the
game I don't know where everyone is gone
but if the legends of whoa hey I was
reading that did I see a chainsaw I
could've sworn I saw a saw okay anyway
WASD to move if your flashlight flickers
press F to reset it follow the trees Hey
hi hi okay I'm in an office but this
doesn't look like any office building
I've ever seen why is my desk right by a
giant pipe well what kind of hellish
working environment is this I mean I've
worked in bad places but this I would
likely tell my boss that this isn't
adequate I don't I don't flickr up hello
I can jump really high
why am i stuck in an office job if I can
jump this high hello is anybody out
there
I don't know the story buying this game
but lockers what why are there so many
lockers that were like two cubicles I
don't know maybe I'm taking the game
logic a bit too seriously oh I would say
I wish moat
alright somebody uh hello I haven't seen
a mannequin in a game in a long time so
uh go [ __ ] yourself
okay anyway so um I wish that some games
would just do a fundamental stupid are
they facing me what huh are they turning
Gorge me they aren't they they they
actually are forgot what was that
hello is somebody actually there oh boy
this is not gonna be fun is it for me
for you it'll be hilarious but for me
it's not gonna be fun
a box of just twisted looking box
pallets Oh such a mystic looking palette
hey wait there's no alley Oh in case you
guys didn't know I absolutely hate
mannequins and then followed me ha ha I
love all of all the things I hate in
horror games mannequins are like number
one I don't know why they just freak me
out ok
don't judge me don't judge me Oh snot I
was not there before
ah
ah stop ahead go away I don't want any
good
go to hell preferably it's following me
can I run I cannot is there any item
here that I need ah come on
okay I'm just going I'm just going okay
so here are all the cubicles ah what am
I supposed to do here there's nothing I
can do what am I do there's nothing I
can use there's no items here there's
literally nothing what are you doing
here go to hell
it's my flashlight if I turn around are
you you don't seem to be getting any
closer than that point so you stay there
got to do the mousekedance
I'm gonna go buy you hopefully you don't
kill me what's up with the I can move
you oh oh oh
liquor flicker flicker okay you stay
over there
died a fire literally cuz you're a
mannequin you go up like a lit match was
that is that important can I click on it
nope okay
so I think it said I don't know I
remember there being an interactive
button but I'm mashing II and I'm
clicking on a few things but I haven't
seen anything yet wait was this here
before this was not this is new this is
different this is a different area I
don't know if places are opening up or
maybe this isn't who's air hi a door
always open up yeah oh crap I'm outside
that's not a good thing
look at these amazing mountains they're
so realistic the way they just jut
straight up from the ground a few feet
and then go immediately back down okay
whatever
is that mannequin chill okay good seems
like the manikins have a effed off ah
what what don't just make noises and
have nothing happen make a noise and do
something be interesting
still don't know my objective but
there's a lovely piece of grass
it seems greener than the other grass oh
no it's just my little ass like okay so
I'm wandering through the woods looking
for Oh No
hey wait why is this grass oh it's on a
mountain a mini mountain jutting up from
that grass right there
I can't run so I can't go any faster
than this unfortunately still don't know
what I'm looking for though I guess I'm
seeking refuge and from something in my
weird-ass office building in the middle
of the woods in the middle of the mini
mountains I don't know I don't know and
then there's just weird noises going on
I actually thought that those noises
correspondent with something but right
now I'm just kind of alone no one to
help me can I climb these yes I can I
bet there's no invisible walls and I'm
about to yep yep there's the edge of map
let's not fall off of that please and
thank you I'm good at breaking games but
let's not just do anything intentionally
stupid I mean there's woods you remind
me of slender Dan probably because it's
made on the Unity engine and they use
shared assets like the trees and the
grass and the ground kind of look the
similar the similar they kind of look
the similar to the stop flickering I'm
fixing you okay nothing over there
nothing over here actually what it does
remind me of his Teletubbies or Slendy
Tubby's because they had these weird
pharmacist flashlights stop being a
douche I'm gonna just start mashing f
randomly yeah I can't find anything
which is kind of sad because it got a
broke two preysing who's getting I was
getting good there in the beginning with
the mannequins and stuff but
I'm not finding anything now hahaha
hello what are you doing out here you
shouldn't be out in the cold why are you
here why are you here
how did you get so close you you weren't
anywhere near me what am I looking for
tell me your secrets I've been here
before I don't know stop flickering okay
weird random noises nothing special
static looping and being sounds nothing
special nothing nothing nothing nothing
a whole lot of nothing
what the hell ha ha ha ha ha ha ha stuck
on a mountain a just going for a little
climb oh what's that oh that you're
sliding down oh what's that
ha look at it look at it look it look it
look at it ha oh yeah stupid you look
y'all stupid you look flying down that
mountain thinking I don't notice you're
moving there ha ha ha how stupid could
you be alright whatever as cool mechanic
though I do like that
not really it's stupid ok I've been
wandering in the woods for about five
minutes now and I haven't been able to
find anything stop flickering tomorrow
the flashlight mechanic I don't ever
know what the purpose of that is it's
just kind of annoying it's an extra
hassle
was there something no okay thought I
saw something I did not miss manis
somewhere behind me I don't even see the
building anymore that I came into the
woods from or came out of into the woods
I don't know what that well what's this
what's this what's this eh is this the
building no this is different
alright found something what is this
it's a car ah ah
why oh that's the end all right then
yeah well well done with the mannequins
don't know what's with them right now
but uh it could use it could use a bit
more threat from the mannequins out be
great because I could touch him and push
him and they didn't do anything so um
but remember it is still in beta it's in
beta and there's like just the first
level it's just it's just experimental
stuff they're throwing out there either
way it was put together pretty well for
what it was which was just an early
introduction to something but anyway
keep it up you can do something good
with this I imagine and I really hate
mannequins but that's just me personally
I hate mannequins for some reason ever
since nightmare house - I hate
mannequins I never even knew I did it
before that anyway so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
China
Oh
bud